un autre chiffre hallucinant celui-là 16
milliards de bouteilles plastiques oui
milliards sont produites chaque année en
france
problème seulement un peu plus de la
moitié sont recyclés mais depuis
quelques mois de drôles de machines ont
fait leur apparition dans certains
supermarchés
elle transforme vos bouteilles en paille
est recyclable exemple dans un
supermarché de contre en loir-et-cher
avec paul boyer on scanne la bouteille
directement ici à les avaler dans la
dans la machine
celle ci cette bouteille là en fait va
directement dans le broyeur et ça nous
fait donc des paillettes et une fois
vous avez terminé vous de votre action
vous appuyez sur j'ai fini et ça vous
sort un bon d'achat pour justement aller
dans le magasin cette machine made in
france baptisé bebot attire tous les
regards depuis une semaine
le supermarché de contre tenait à
proposer ce service à ses clients à
chaque bouteilles recyclées
l'utilisateur cumul des points ou des
centimes
il peut choisir sur l'écran tactile
d'imprimer son ticket ou bien de faire
un don à une association d'avoir un bon
d'achat justement pour réutiliser dans
notre magasin ou appuyez sur la touche
dont qui permet d'aller à l'association
nettoyage de nos clients du côté des
clients les retours sont positifs
intrigué pour la plupart ils commencent
à se prêter au jeu les problèmes dans la
nature parce que de toute façon tout ce
qui peut servir au recyclage ce
formidable parce qu'il y en a assez de
tous ces emballages côté financier sera
traitée aussi beaucoup de monde mais oui
préserver l'environnement c'est
forcément attrayant ainsi en un peu plus
de 1000 bouteilles ont été recyclées
depuis le début de la semaine
belle manière de lier utilité et gestes
écologiques